marvin is in his early 30s and utterly
unsuccessful currently he works as a
clerk in the evidence department of a
police station but his ultimate goal is
to become a policeman the reason marvin
wants to be a policeman so desperately
is that his father was killed on duty he
wants to pay homage to his father but at
the rate his life is going the dream
might never come true the next day is
the selection for the police force it
turns out in the last selection process
marvin didn't just fail but humiliated
himself after peeing his pants the
competition starts and marvin is
immediately behind everyone forgetting
which way he should run he makes several
foolish mistakes throughout the course
and fails the test again it doesn't come
as a surprise to anyone as the entire
police force is used to seeing marvin
lose back at home marvin is watching tv
when a particular commercial attracts
his attention it is advertising a
supplement made of 25
badger milk which magically makes men
gain muscles fascinated by the women in
the commercial marvin decides to get a
can for himself the next day at work
marvin is left alone in the office while
the rest of the crew goes outside to
play baseball just then he gets a phone
call from a lady complaining about a
group of robbers threatening to kill
people marvin quickly informs his
colleagues through a microphone but they
do not hear him in the field he thinks
of it as a chance to prove his worth and
decides to go to the location himself he
hopes to save the day and become
everyone's hero but the plan goes
downhill when he is met with an accident
on the way his vehicle flies off the
road and down a hill when it gets dark a
man in a gorilla costume comes to his
rescue and drags him to a hideout the
man happens to be a doctor who fixes
marvin and keeps him back at the crash
site upon waking up marvin is confused
but the memory of the crash soon comes
back to him he is glad he doesn't have a
single broken bone and doesn't remember
the doctor at all following that he
returns home still hazy from the
medicines he was given a dog that used
to always attack him leaps at him once
again but strangely enough it stops
midway and runs back to its kennel the
special bodybuilding supplement has been
delivered to his house although it
doesn't look appetizing marvin gulps it
down hoping to gain superhuman strength
after the shower he wiggles himself like
a dog to dry off he doesn't think much
of it but when he turns around that day
he returns to work and finds out he's
been missing for an entire week his
friends ask him to go to the doctor but
marvin feels better than ever what he
doesn't know is that the doctor who
treated him after the crash has replaced
his damaged organs with those of animals
because some parts of the brain were
exchanged for her dogs marvin has gained
some characteristics of a dog similarly
he also feels the emotions of a bird a
cat a horse and many other animals
during his morning jog marvin surprises
himself by racing a horse he attributes
it to the special supplement he ate
yesterday and is happy that it worked he
also bumps into a woman named rihanna
walking her dogs in the park she is an
animal lover and was recently on the
news for spending an entire night on a
tree as they talk marvin notices a man
throwing a frisbee he cannot suppress
his urges and ends up catching the
frisbee with his mouth later that day he
goes to meet a friend at the airport
because of his heightened sense of smell
he can tell that a man has illegal
substances on him the security checks
the guy at marvin's request but doesn't
find anything however an adamant martin
stops the guy again and brings out a
package he had hidden inside his behind
everyone claps for marvin praising his
intelligence and bravery because of his
contribution he is finally deemed fit to
be a police officer sticking your nose
up other people's butts a surefire way
to get ahead in any industry after years
of waiting the day finally comes when he
is appointed to duty later he is on his
way back home when the doctor who
treated him after the crash stops him
his name is dr wilder a mad scientist
who is obsessed with human animal fusion
he tells marvin the truth about his
newfound abilities the doctor wanted to
see how marvin will adapt to life as a
new person but now that he is gaining
attention he has to be sustained when
marvin refuses to oblige he is hit with
a tranquilizer gun according to the
doctor soon marvin won't be able to
suppress his animalistic urges which
might create trouble for the people
around him still marvin refuses to be
confined as an animal and runs away from
the barn where he was abducted a few
days later the doctor's concerns come to
life when marvin starts digging into the
trash for bones thrown by his colleagues
but more problems arise as his sexual
needs start escalating upon seeing women
on the street he cannot help but to hump
a mailbox he even feels attracted to a
catfish because of how its mouth looks i
feel like we have a word for this in
modern society on the brighter side he
starts feeling more compassionate
towards animals and impresses rihanna by
feeding a bird with his mouth she is an
animal lover and owns a lot of them the
duo becomes closer because of their
shared interest the following morning
marvin wakes up in a meat shop with his
belly protruding out of his shirt he
immediately goes to the doctor and asks
him for help dr wilder wants to keep him
as a pet but marvin insists that he is
happy in his life as a policeman he only
needs some assistance hence the doctor
teaches him how to endure and suppress
the urges he makes marvin eat a lot of
meat and trains him like a dog the next
day marvin and the sergeant go out to a
farm to investigate some missing animals
marvin carries toys and treats with him
to distract himself whenever he gets the
urge to do something then he shouldn't
on the farm marvin's eyes land upon a
goat who has been separated from the
other animals because they cannot resist
her strangely enough marvin also feels
the same but is kicked away by the
animal before he can get too close to
her on their way back the sergeant sees
rihanna walking her dogs unaware that
she is interested in marvin he hits on
her when rihanna rejects him for his
junior the officer's ego is hurt as a
result he makes it his mission to get
marvin kicked out of the police force
following the interaction the two go to
a high-profile party organized by the
city's mayor everything goes well until
a cat snarls at marvin and triggers his
dog-like urges he disturbs the entire
party to chase after the cat in the end
he has to be stopped by his colleagues
the mayor is furious at him for ruining
the party he asks the head of the police
to kick marvin out as soon as he gets
the chance right then marvin hears a
splash and follows the sound it turns
out the mayor's son has dropped into a
pond and is drowning marvin jumps just
at the right moment to save the kid the
mayor is beyond thankful to him
alongside all the guests even the
sergeant starts respecting marvin after
the incident later that day marvin and
rihanna go out to a restaurant on a date
marvin keeps his urges in check for the
most part but when rihanna goes to the
washroom for a while he pees under the
table after smelling it rihanna returns
and recognizes the horrible smell but
marvin passes it as the restaurant's
fault as they chat her dress slips off
her shoulder an animal like marvin
cannot control himself anymore so he
goes to the washroom to finish his
business seconds after returning he
notices her turning around and has to
make a second trip to the bathroom
throughout the dinner marvin notices a
waiter trying to flirt with rihanna and
getting a little too close to her later
he finds the man outside the restaurant
and attacks him out of jealousy upon
returning home rihanna invites marvin
inside but he doesn't want to risk
attacking her so he politely declines
the offer but instead of returning home
he subconsciously goes on a rampage on
the nearby farm in the following scene
the farm owner is at the police station
complaining about a beast who attacked
his animals last night the head officer
recognizes the culprit's sketch and
calls marvin to his office as the man
scolds marvin for his inhuman behavior
marvin licks his legs and crotch area in
the end he is suspended from the police
force for a month to work on himself a
few days pass before we see him again
rihanna goes to his house and finds it
turned into a nest with hay and branches
everywhere marvin wants her to go away
for her own safety because he doesn't
trust himself however rihanna knows that
he is having problems but still trusts
him when she insists on staying the
night marvin comes up with a solution
and asks her to tie his hands but things
get steamy pretty quickly and they end
up spending the night together since
marvin's hands are not bound he goes on
a rampage yet again in the morning he
wakes up beside rihanna before the two
can enjoy time together the police
arrives outside the house this time they
are sure that marvin was behind the
chaos that occurred at night rihanna
knowing that marvin is innocent makes
him run out the window using his new
skills marvin is able to get away from
the police but the news about him being
a cow assaulter makes it to the
television the city's finest officers
and civilians join hands to organize a
search party for him they are all armed
and ready to kill marvin as soon as they
find him in the meantime marvin is
running through the woods when he comes
across dr wilder up a tree the doctor
says he was picking apples but his dart
gun proves otherwise upon being urged to
tell the truth he reveals that he
performed the exact same experiment on
someone else and that person is the one
killing the animals not marvin they set
out to look for the person but the
doctor fractures his foot leaving marvin
on his own when no one is around we see
the doctor take his socks off to reveal
his animal-like foot gross the sergeant
has set up a piece of meat in the middle
of the forest marvin falls right into
his trap and leaps for the meat only to
be showered with bullets he somehow
manages to climb a tree without getting
shot after a long chase the sergeant
almost falls off a cliff but is saved by
marvin when asked why he saved his rival
marvin replies that he is not an animal
still the sergeant stays true to his
duty and points his gun at him right
then rihanna jumps up on top of him and
knocks him out revealing that she is
also dr wilder's patient she hopes that
the revelation doesn't change anything
between her and marvin's relationship
marvin agrees and the two kiss but then
the mob surrounds the duo wanting to
kill both of them marvin's friend miles
takes the blame for everything revealing
that he killed the animals upon finding
out that a black man was responsible the
police don't want to take action anymore
they disperse as if nothing ever
happened
what a crazy joke to end this movie on
one year later marvin and rihanna are
married and have two children of their
own while watching television they see
dr wilder win the nobel prize for his
experiments he credits his fiancee
yolanda and kisses her to display large
scars on her back implying that she is
also half human and half animal
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching